hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the uncle who works for
Nintendo now this horror game is going
to be way different than anything that
you've seen on this channel before
because this one is an interactive
horror game well I guess most horror
games are interactive but this one
actually has to choose your own
adventure style narrative-driven horror
game if that may seem weird it might be
I don't know how it's gonna go but it
says there are tons of jump scares which
could be good or bad you are 11 years
old what is your best friend's name none
of these people I don't know if this
matters but I'm gonna go with Dave your
best friend dave has invited you to a
sleepover at his house this weekend
yippee you've been friends since first
grade so asking your mom is basically
only a formality
you've never confirmed this but you
suspect the babysitter may charge extra
when there are two kids you sometimes
feel like staying somewhere else is the
only way you can help out oh oh that's
sweet damn sad oh he's trying to help
out your mom oh cool
I'm Friday night you're home for only a
few hours long enough to pack it in the
fight with your younger sister pack some
more and watch some TV at 6:00 sharp
you're standing on the sidewalk outside
Dave's house while your mom idles in the
car nearby she leans out the window to
you you behave yourself ok she says as
always I'll be at work but if anything
happens you call me oh ok mom gah Oh mom
works the night shift oh I'll pick you
up tomorrow at 3:00 she says again as
usual but then she pauses looking up to
the sky which has been overcast
throughout the day if you play outside
she adds be careful it's probably gonna
rain well I'm not gonna give my mom a
kiss right in front of Dave I can't
embarrass myself like that I'm a young
boy after you part your mom drives down
the street to Spearing around the corner
you turn back Dave's house the lights
inside are glowing warmly you can see
Dave waving at you from his bedroom on
the second floor he would have seen he
would have seen that and he would have
made fun of me I can't have none of
it is 6 yeah I've been played a 2-0
adventure game like this I mean I played
games like this before
and the details are very important in
these types of games so you have to pay
attention to the dialogue very closely
Dave's mom meets you just inside hello
she says dinner will be ready in just a
few minutes but you can drop stuff off
in the den you and Dave are camping out
there tonight
cool Thanks Dave's mom ah you're the
coolest pretty cool is my mom
you drop your sleeping and overnight
back to the corner of the den and then
pause to take a look around
behind the couches grandfather clock
ticking softly through a set of patio
doors on the far side of the room you
can see the sky is just as grey as it
was when your mom left framed pictures
lined the walls over the dark fireplace
hangs a monstrous pair of antlers from a
buck that Dave's dad shot years ago and
of course there's the big-screen TV
sometimes it makes you uncomfortable how
much nicer Dave's house is in yours oh
man I'm an ungrateful brat kid Oh your
mom's trying my mom's driving Dave
entered the room while you weren't
paying attention and he now stands in
the doorway smiling expectantly are you
ready for dinner he asks sure yeah heck
yeah I haven't had dinner in days dinner
passes quickly tonight's meal is
spaghetti and meatballs one of Dave's
favorite meals as his mother points out
while piling and helping on your plate
Dave's father cracks a beer and Joe Vuli
interrogate cyou about how much trouble
you and Dave are getting into its school
wait that wasn't a beer at all that's a
glasses lemonade why would you even
think it was beer Dave's father doesn't
drink alcohol you're quite certain to
that fact now that you remember it well
whatever
Dave's father's Oh
ah this is what I meant by paying
attention to details because that
changed the story just a little bit just
a little bit I think that's like a
tutorial introduction to if you pay
attention it's gonna do different things
okay
the grandfather clock chimes in the den
you go along now says Dave's mom smiling
from her side of the table we'll clean
up in here let's go get the TV ready
says Dave the to you leave the dining
room and head upstairs Dave's room is
immense
you stay in the den because the TD is
larger there but there's a sizable one
here flush with the wall opposite the
full-size bed we'll take down the 64
first says Dave heading towards the TV
and opening the entertainment center
cabinet it's his prerogative of course
he gets to choose what you play first
usually but as Dave's begins unhooking
the cores of the n64 from the TV you
catch sight of other things he has in
there all the major stuff an old snez US
PlayStation a Dreamcast but some other
things too things you don't really
recognize a large black box with green
highlights a small purple one a strange
white and yellow tower that looks like
gloves resting on hooks on the other
side
compact white cone what are those Dave
looks to the clutter in the cabinet oh
yeah they're pretty cool I can't show
them to you though they're still secret
I promised my uncle
of course you suddenly remember his home
uncle works for Nintendo in the corner
grip
oh it's video it's VG games it didn't
sound good the grandfather clock is
ticking it's 7:00 p.m.
framed pictures he walked with a brown
the perimeter of the den inspecting the
pictures idly most of them are family
portrait from years past they'd cradled
lovely would be between his mother and
father or any of the three on their own
happy tidy family look for pictures of
Dave's uncle very important you don't
find any not one the only pictures here
are of Dave and his parents you don't
know why but that makes you feel uneasy
time passes oh I did oh oh cool okay why
do I need to think about Dave's uncle
why why do i why why is that an option
I'm gonna go that's just so weird
it began with mu did it you didn't
believe him at first but when Dave came
to school one day and told you you'd
finally caught him you prove it you said
so he pulled out his gameboy and showed
you there it was mu 150 first Pokemon
available only to players of promotional
events somehow unlocked on Dave's game
it's really strong k oz every enemy in
one hit they've demonstrated this claim
at recess when you and some of the other
friends late game boys to do battle you
were the first one down no one else got
a single hit on Dave's view the few days
everyone had quit playing Pokemon of
resources
faded you asked how I managed to get it
oh my uncle got a job a Nintendo said
Dave we're walking home together
that's him one of the construction crews
there had been a storm not too long ago
trees were down all over the town
building a collapse you were standing at
the intersection with Dave as a truck
rumbled by loaded up with ragged tree
trunks what a bad storm Dave still licks
in it lived next door to you at the time
wait this couldn't have been too long
ago when did they move it was something
nice about being neighbors man your
memory is really foggy here he also got
me this new Gameboy pulling out his
pockets you hadn't noticed earlier but
yes Dave now how to sleep new gameboy
color until today he only had one of the
old ones a big great brick like yours
this one's a special edition isn't it
cool
you agreed jealously you snap out of
your reflections the clock chimes is it
8:00 it's 8:00 now or is it 9:00 it's
8:00 okay remember your own miu what
what did I when would I ever know I mean
you got your own move any another friend
at a gameshark which you borrowed one
day you spend that entire night
unlocking every pokemon you couldn't
obtain in your copy of the game or
hadn't traded in yet including new
didn't one-hit ko most enemies it was
incredibly weak and you shamefully
cheated the game further to make it
strong enough it even looked different
from Dave's your new is small even cute
standing there with its round here
phille eyes but when Dave's had wiped
out everyone at school it had a
completely different compact snarling
fierce yes why what he said that had
been here in the dead oh that thing
David moved by then but how long was
that after the first storm after he got
me you can't remember it had been a
while since anyone talked about Pokemon
while my uncle got me the special
edition Mew first of all he said
spurning a little but not looking away
from the PlayStation game he was playing
that's why mine looked different second
of all mine can one-hit ko because it's
the real yes what he meant by that just
what I said you cheated and got a fake
commute so of course there'd be problems
glitches and junk you felt your cheeks
reddened but not me I got the real new
and only me my brother was so jealous
Dave's brother what about him why does
remembering that common make you feel
uneasy you snap out of your reflections
I'm not sure what's going on here but it
looks like I'm out of things to remember
and it's only 8:30
how about talk to Dave ask him if he
thinks a storm will be as bad as the
last one that might be important
considering oh geez
considering I'm wondering if he
remembers the storm considering memories
seem to be a little kerfuffle I don't
like the sound of the wind do you
remember the storm we had the tore down
all the trees I don't know what you're
talking about I knew it I knew it things
are a little here you don't remember
remember what I actually forgot until
tonight there was a huge storm a few
weeks ago I think if it was important
I'm sure I would have remembered it
oh no you don't remember how about games
bring up the subject the new Pokemon
games through the rumors you heard on
the internet when you were supposed to
be working in school they've
meticulously debunks and confirms
everything you have to say all based on
of course what his uncle told him our
passes Dave's mother bustles into the
room holding his large ceramic bowl
filled with popcorn under her arm how
are you kids doing she asked good says
dave is my eyes not moving from the
television I hope you're having fun
here's some popcorn
Extra Butter you're welcome almost
immediately dave is shoveling popcorn
into his mouth meanwhile his mother
smiles first to him then back at you the
sodas in the kitchen if you get thirsty
and some pizzas sell from the other
night if you get hungry thank you thank
you
your father's gone to bed I'll be here
soon I'll be there soon myself I want
you two to keep it quiet all right
yes mom Owen before I forget your uncle
called he suddenly had some business
here in town tomorrow but he's driving
an early he'll be here around midnight
oh that doesn't sound good at all oh no
for the first time Dave stops playing
his game stops even popcorn Durst look
his mother okay he says I want you two
to welcoming him they'll be very tired
very hungry so offer him something to
eat before he goes to bed okay mom good
night kids
and she's gone it's buttery delicious
okay what about this uncle why does he
come in business but I thought he'd
worked for Nintendo he does frowning but
not looking away from the TV he's really
important there doesn't intend to have a
lot of business here why else would my
uncle be coming as if you've asked the
dumbest question of the world well it's
cool I'll finally get to meet him
yeah I think you'll like him it sort of
worked as your uncle do they pauses the
game and turns towards you physically
agitated
how would I know I don't work for them
right now he's not quite yelling but you
think if you keep pressing the subject
he might well let's keep pressing the
subject I don't believe you takes a
moment to respond as if he's not quite
heard what you said what I don't believe
your uncle works for a Nintendo you
think you've finally done it
Dave stands up fists clenched at his
size mouth twisting horribly as he
struggled to say something
would you watch as he takes a step
towards you and you clench your teeth
and wait cool
hippy Wow Dave darts forward and pushes
you onto the carpet oh jeez cracking
your skull against the carpet you take
the initiative and just throw a punch
before he can go for you again okay yeah
let's fight you shut yourself up in the
floor and send oh you send your fists
into Dave's stomach for a moment you're
shocked at what you've done is he stands
there gasping in his pajamas but then
suddenly that expression I hate you what
you hear something or you think you hear
something someone's shouting and then
you've fallen flat on the floor for a
moment you don't think he can get up
your whole body feels heavy did he hit
you I hate you says Dave leave me alone
he finally managed to sit up as he turns
back to his game and take a moment to
collect yourself talk to Dave he's tried
to strike up a conversation but David's
too involved in the game it seems to be
ignoring you oh boy okay maybe I could
call my mom passing through the empty
dining or me under the kitchen where the
phone sits in the corner what'd you
explain what that that you and Dave
aren't getting along right now and you'd
like to go home early something in your
voice seems to give her pause okay I'll
call the sitter and tell her to come
pick you up it'll probably be an hour is
that okay yes yes thank you
of course I'll call her now she'll be
there in an hour be safe return to the
den and pack your things
clock chimes Dave doesn't even look away
from the TV as you come in and now
instead I'm gonna tell him I'm leaving
what you can't leave
it's almost time almost time for what
you can't go there's so much stuff I had
planned for tonight I was gonna let you
play the next Zelda game the ones that
not even out yet before you can say
anything he's already running upstairs
Dave continually runs up and down the
stairs bringing you games and consoles
while you pack your things
every time he presents something new you
ignore him or brush
with an uncaring shrunken please just
stay stay the night please a side of
your car
no marched to the front door and exit
into the night walk to the city's car
your little sister in the backseat
seller in pajamas sitter my school girl
who lives down the street from you looks
incredibly unhappy to be there but you
think you'll be able to handle her is
climb into the car you cast one last
look over your shoulder back to the
house dave is standing there in the
doorway totally still not screaming not
crying not doing much of anything the
car begins to pull away from the houses
as you watch you see his parents appear
in the doorway behind him wave without
acknowledging you Dave's parents lay
their hands on his shoulders they turned
Dave back into the house the door
closing just as everything slides out of
you and you turn around in your seat you
can't even see the houses lights Dave
doesn't show up to school on Monday or
Tuesday or Wednesday on Thursday you ask
your teacher mr. Scott where Dave won he
blinks at you confusedly Oh Dave well
I'm surprised he didn't tell you about
this but he and his family moved away
the house is empty when you ride by your
bike by that afternoon it somehow seems
even larger without anything or anyone
in it a for sale sign in the front yard
never see Dave again and eventually as
the years pass you forget about him
entirely huh ah there's five there's
five endings plus one secret one okay
we're gonna be here a while okay so I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna try to find
all of them I don't know if I'm going to
but we're gonna try oh this is important
oh this is actually a very important
detail so I'm going back right now all
right so no he doesn't drink
okay so now I'm gonna think about Dave's
uncle and I'm gonna remember this stuff
began with mu I'll get back when I when
I'm to the point and I'm not gonna get
in a fight with Dave okay here we go
so your uncle stays with you when he
visits he lives pretty far away so he
just drops by isn't that a little weird
it gives you a look like you don't that
you don't like very much how would you
know you don't even have an uncle oh
jeez that's a little that's a little
antagonistic yeah I guess so oh geez
okay so it's getting closer to midnight
it's now 10 o'clock so I guess I could
check the pictures again whoa wait
something's wrong here where's Dave's
brother you know he has a brother you
know it except except he's not here in
any of the pictures think harder about
the brother he was older not much one or
two years a jerk sometimes but not any
more of a jerk than you are to your
little sister when it snowed your mom
would let him shovel the sidewalk
outside your house he lived next door
his name you can't remember his name ask
Dave about his brother is your brother
spreading the night with one of his
friends Dave pauses the game he's
playing gives you an odd look I don't
have a brother
I remember him there's a long
uncomfortable silence broken only by
distant thunder a Nintendo
clock ticking you're such a weirdo
subject it seems that's been the
grandfather clock chimes the hours Dave
suddenly looks up from the 64 it's time
he says it's not being weird
that's quite a knocker that's him I
should go let him in as he leaves the
den you realize you could follow the
part of you feels really like being
scarce for a bit I'll follow him up
brave the knocking continues pursue
outside the pebbled glass on the front
window you can see a tall dark shadow
Dave goes to the door undoes the
deadbolt and cracks it open you can come
in he says to whoever stands on the
board then look over his shoulder at you
sorry he says before you can ask what
there's to be sorry about the door slams
open batiks oh hello child come closer
child
no worries child I'm a hungry child no
worries child hello child well who
features none screaming seats oh geez
okay
oh okay oh that was bad idea oh that was
a bad idea it's a bad idea to turn that
thing bad idea
he met the uncle whoo-ha I met him I
sure didn't met him oh and then I left
early okay going back bites you to play
wins every round pretty easily in this
made a mistake he's a super competitive
and frankly a lot better
good game he says smirking I need to
take a break whatever you say dick
Dave's a douche okay fridge cold pizza
so I'm going to I have to go to the
bathroom oh I do don't die whoa what's
going on here what what happened what
what was that closet completely empty
walls a strange on texture Dwight what's
going on here what the hell is happening
toilet you realize something wrong with
the toilet the water in Bowl looks solid
like glass when you attempt to turn the
handle nothing happens but the toilet
emits a sound of flushing anyway you
suddenly don't feel like having to go
anymore what is going on here uh okay
that's weird it's like I'm in a video I
don't want to play games anymore
it's the donk okay that's him I should
let him get in I'm gonna be scarce this
time I'm gonna run out of all the
bathroom and lock the door behind you at
least this could have been the bathroom
the walls are bare and white there's no
sink or toilet but this mod featureless
white boxes that could stand in for a
shower or a linen oh you can hear the
front door slam open
after that you don't hear anything child
butchie's Lorraine no not just a rain
but that voice in the background like
I'm coming for your child like something
you can't even begin to describe will
you lock the door behind you something
walked in you're not exactly sure how
you know something out there because you
don't exactly go child you're moving but
you know it's there you know it stopped
poor poor child right outside things but
it opens the door even though you don't
immediately realize it doesn't have any
hands oh jeez oh I am so hungry child
you cannot run shout hello hello hey
friends for you well then I ran which is
a thing okay ooh
there might be an ending where if you
call your mom at exactly 11:00 and then
the babysitter comes at the same time as
the uncle I think that might be one of
them okay okay so these are clues to the
ending some things you remember don't
match what you see learn what you can't
ask questions have a serious talk don't
be mean but still get out of there okay
so get out of there
I think and there's other ones the same
thing but and then make what might be
the worst decision ever so I think that
one is calling at the same time so let
me see if that is what it is
ah okay you remember the storm yeah you
say nodding but no one remembers the
storm ah it was big it took down trees
that's impossible impossible no one
remembers it what's going on here he he
came out of the storm and I was home
alone
Dave begins his eyes growing distant mom
was at work dad was that was out at a
bar where was your brother
yeah you remember him - he was there
upstairs he said it was the brightest
lightning he ever saw
then the knocking started but I'm then I
answered the door when the knocking
started he said he was lost and hungry
he said he could help me and all I had
to do is promise to feed him okay Dave
tenses what is that it's my uncle or
that's what he told me to call him I
don't really know I don't know what he
it is kidding right what did he do he
changed things he said he could make
things happen any way I wanted them to
that I would always be the best as long
as as long as I fed him what did you
have to feed him they've looked at you
his eyes watering for a long time he
doesn't say anything and then suddenly
you understand no you can't you can't
he's already on his way there it is
like a voice not something you hear
exactly but still in the back of your
mind
see see he's almost here I'm calling my
mom things are really weird I just want
to go home turn to the den Dave sitting
silently on the floor as you come in
you're leaving aren't you I don't want
to be friends with you anymore
this joke you're playing is really me
should have known it was different you
were remembering too much if your uncle
is so powerful why can't he just keep me
here
it gets weak he can't do as much is that
why things have been different is he
weaker now please please don't go I've
never not fed him and if I don't I'm not
sure what will happen so you just want
me to get eaten there whatever no please
no it's not I think he'll kill me do you
understand he would get have killed me
if I didn't shut up and leave me alone
you can tell the Dave is on the verge of
tears but nevertheless he does as you
asked walking over to sit in the middle
of the den as you finished packing car
honks outside Dave wandered over the
fireplace is looking into it's unlit
death
citiz Oh the front doors closed
you suddenly can't remember if you did
that yourself still burning as a sitter
pulls away you stare at the window
Dave's house alight blurred and
magnified by the rain streaming
eventually it slides out of you find out
next afternoon about the fire started in
the dens in the papers where there was
known to be a fireplace apparently left
smoldering and night no survivors
arson is expected since an accelerant
would have helped the plane's overcome
the night's heavy rains but nothing
definitive is ever publicly released
when they after school you ride your
bike to check it out parts of the house
still stand walls and beams blackened by
flames yellow caution tape you decide to
investigate oh oh the second floor is
either mostly burned away or fallen
through but standing on what used to be
the den you look up the hole that would
have been Dave's room broken glass and
charred drywall crunch beneath your feet
until you step on something that isn't
glass you look down and the mess is what
looks like a gameboy it's a gameboy
color
not at all scuffed or damaged but the
back is a single cartridge a copy of
pokemon blue ooh that'd be a bad idea
I'm a pokemon red kind of guy okay you
leave the ruined house and hop back on
your bike pedaling home your mom doesn't
have to work tonight since she knows
you're taking recent events hard she's
promised to take you and your little
sister to the movies you don't think
about Dave at all and my god well oh
okay oh so the last standing would have
been and then I believe this probably a
secret ending would have been if you
picked up the Gameboy because it
mentioned and then they make what might
be the worst decision ever so I'm gonna
go quickly do that real quick okay you
take Dave's Gameboy looking from side to
side as if anyone who might actually be
watching you pick up the gameboy and
flick on the power switch after clicking
do it the pokemons interest means you
find there is no safe game in the cart
it's like a brand new copy turn off the
gameboy and stuffing in your pocket
return home
your mom is standing in the kitchen when
you arrive doing dishes your little
sister is watching some annoying cartoon
remember to take a bath and get dressed
before 7:00 remember you're fairly
certain she never told you to do that in
the first place
walk into the kitchen dropping your
backpack on the linoleum for why do I
need to do all that silly she says your
mom turns from the sink to smile at you
and your throat tightens when you see
how glassy and empty her eyes are don't
you remember your uncle is coming for
dinner to celebrate his new job BAM that
was a dumb decision why'd you pick up
this stupid game boy what did you do
that oh hello what's this okay oink
aha repetition with a difference it is
not time for running go where you're not
wanted go where you've been told you
can't go ah repetition with a difference
okay I think I understand what that
means I think I was starting to get it
when the walls were kind of changing and
shifting you know what I mean
okay go to the kitchen Dave's mom and
dad are still there so oh the table
hasn't yet been cleared and they're
still sitting in the exact same places
you left them in fact you realize they
aren't moving at all how did I miss this
they sit there completely still like
mannequins Dave's dad is holding up his
glass of lemonade as if getting ready to
take a drink Dave's mom has already had
her head turned and her mouth slightly
open as if she froze immediately after
you and Dave left the dining room you
okay
they don't respond Thunder rumbles
outside they don't seem to notice please
are you okay they aren't even blinking
pass them into the kitchen you're in the
kitchen the dining room is behind you
you can grab something from the fridge
I'm gonna grab a soda exit the kitchen
back to the den tell Dave about his
parents what see your parents are
sitting in the dining room still they're
not moving they're not even blinking
are you sure I bet they're just being
weird give me a second you can play my
games if you want play a little they
look fine to me mom says she's gonna
bring him some popcorn but I saw them
nice try for a prank though on one more
thing thanks for sending me out mom made
me help her clean up after all special
company what Oh my uncle's coming to
visit so mom comes in give us a popcorn
nod silently super weird this passage
does not exist Kenshin oh this passage
does not exist go anyway what no child
you go to the kitchen there's not much
of a this is not allowed child tell the
chat tell the uncool to be quiet
it falls silent for a moment it's grown
weak since you haven't been feeding it
take out the Gameboy from your pocket
whoa the uncle is somewhere behind a
half textured walls grumbling to itself
turn on the gameboy bogie Dex there
isn't time to use that pokemon item
you're carrying Gameboy Color Me you
hope this works this works oh it came to
you after you picked up Dave's Gameboy
still weak from the night of the
sleepover in that moment you haven't
understanding for what it was and what
it did how many times that you man not
made it through the night how many of
your friends had gone before you would
come after you how many had taken the
Gameboy and promised you what it
promised everyone every time the newest
games the best consoles the best
strategies and most talent the knowledge
and tricks and secrets a family who
couldn't would provide these things you
could play well play forever you would
always be the best so long as you've fed
it and you had an idea it did not like
your first request but it was hungry and
it had no other choice so here you are
Oh save probably not a good idea to save
when things are getting messed up option
tech speed fast you're 11 years old was
your best friend named David ed they
invited sleepover you've been in friends
for eternity for plans oh of course you
suddenly remember his uncle in the
corner Oh grandfather clock ticking
softly Dave's parked in for the large TV
playing that's it for suddenly he jumps
up if scared him by entering what was
that I know about the Uncle Dave blinks
uneasily I don't know what you mean what
are you talking about
I used to come back here I hear it too
it's alright how's this happening I'm
starving it to death
what are you here I came back to save
you it doesn't control you it may seem
like it does it may seem like it's all
you have but it's not it lies
it always lies all that all the others
they're gone
no we're here we're all here still it
doesn't eat all once it's slow it takes
years maybe even forever I made so many
my parents my brother I don't deserve it
why did you come back for me why'd you
come back for me
because we're friends things are
starting it - oh God dave is still
crying take Dave's hand
okay
Oh dick days and here you really came
back you think we can do this
it wants us to hate each other and I
won't do that let's go ah Oh goodbye
gonna exit now no no no no no coming
back
these Flicka balls should I click on
these oh ah you don't understand the
games offered me something I didn't have
before they gave me a sense of place
whoo am I talking to the uncle sorry for
all this
oh I'm talking to head Dave okay we can
become something else if we're willing
to fight it it doesn't control us it's
our only it isn't their only choice even
if it wants us to think you are my
friend
no more games you are my friend and I am
here for you Wow well then I'm guessing
that was the new game ending you have
Dave you and Dave have defeated the
uncle who works for Nintendo well there
you have it you unlock the author's
notes okay several endings is game yet
if you're reading this because you've
obtained the ending after which I do not
think there can be any more play if
you'd like more traditional hidden
content please click here
congratulations you've unlocked
alternate outfits for all the character
during your next playthrough do your
best to imagine characters wearing
different outfits oh that's so nice oh
that's lovely maybe there's something to
do that if that actually is a thing let
me let me look that up actually okay no
that is also that is the uncle who works
for Nintendo a really interesting thing
it's like a choose-your-own-adventure
creepypasta because I believe that's
what this is supposed to be it's
supposed to be like creepypasta it's
supposed to be this story it may
actually have been already a story just
put into a an adventure game style game
which was really cool by the way I like
that a lot so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
and as always
in the next video by
[Music]